[Music]
Sydnee dating scene is pretty
superficial but what do people want in a
partner we asked some local Sydneysiders
to rate these to stock photo babes out
of 10 based purely on their looks how
would you rate heavy b-66 yeah lovely
smile he do I suppose
so I'd rate him highly he smiled he
looks peaceful I don't know looks like a
good guy friendly looking he's got a
he's got a nice face just out of ten
purely on looks which I know is
superficial and if you could rate this
man very natural look which is I think
it's a bit rare sometimes so yeah that
just looks natural fresh what we didn't
tell them is there are actually two
versions of the girls and guys one in
red and one in blue we weren't really
trying to measure how hot they thought
the girls and guys were but what they
thought of their t-shirt color choice
scientist of showing that straight men
and women prefer the opposite sex be
wearing red and find them more
attractive
what do our Vic's think I don't know
it's a little bit subjective and just to
narrow someone down to like a number
like ah she's eight oh go hey give that
seven
[Music]
and they okay go in the scientists study
they found that the subjects weren't
actually aware of the effect that read
was having on them but our test subjects
were a little divided on where the color
really met I think it's more how they're
wary rather than what color it is and I
like I I wouldn't say which ones work
for me necessarily but just certain some
outfits into I know work better than
others I guess if you like there's a
specific color and they're wearing that
color then you're obviously gonna think
that they got good taste
yeah not so much color I wouldn't Oh
personally I wouldn't blame me bond
sterile [ __ ] yeah bright red the biggest
lose someone in our study find well the
gals and guys in red we're rated more
attractive than the gals and guys in
blue but not by that much still if you
trust science as I do then you should be
wearing red on your next date
[Music]
you